for the past year we've looked at apples
based 13-inch MacBook Pro as a pretty
bad value compared to Apple's newly
updated MacBook Air and the more
expensive $1,800 touched by a pro since
it packs a pretty slow dual-core
processor and was lacking a few features
but with Apple's new $1300 base MacBook
Pro we've completely changed our mind
and we're now calling it the best value
macbook ever let's discuss everything
that's great and not so great about the
new base model MacBook Pro for starters
Apple is able to equip it with a touch
bar at the same base price something you
previously had to pay eighteen hundred
dollars to get now of course not
everybody likes it but what really
matters is the hardware that comes with
it like touch ID authentication which
makes it really convenient to log in and
install new apps without having to
re-enter your password but the major
deal is Apple's t2 chip which takes care
of a bunch of system controllers and
makes it much more secure and on top of
that it brings Hardware HEV C video
transcoding and many people believe that
HEV C is going to be the future of
mainstream codec so having the two-two
chip makes this MacBook Pro much more
future-proof design wise almost
everything else about the new base
macbook pro basically matches the more
expensive MacBook Pros like the very
color accurate and bright display with
true tone technology the class-leading
force touch trackpad in the all-aluminum
lightweight and incredibly thin design
along with that we also have the latest
version of Apple's butterfly keyboard
similar to the third gen in 2018 but
with updated materials this alone was a
big reason why some people would spend
more for the 2018
$1,800 model or go with a MacBook Air
instead the previous base macbook pro
had a keyboard design from 2016 which
was the most prone to failure now we're
not sure if the latest design will fix
all the problems just yet but if any
issues arise Apple will fix them for
free what really makes this year's base
MacBook Pro stand out is the new quad
core processor and from the first glance
on Apple's website it seems like it's
quite a bit slower than the $1,800
MacBook Pros 2.4 gigahertz processor but
that couldn't be further from the truth
we made a full video comparing both
models and we found that under load the
base MacBook Pro ran only 300 megahertz
slower than the $1,800 model nowhere
near the one gigahertz or a thousand
megahertz difference we saw on the spec
sheet we ran
ton of benchmarks video editing tests
and even some photo editing and found
that the $1,800 MacBook Pro is only
around five to nine percent faster than
the $1,300 model so for performance
alone
it definitely wasn't worth the upgrade
if you're looking to do video editing on
a budget we're able to playback full
resolution 4k h.264 and h.265 files
without any dropped frames and both
Premiere Pro and Final Cut Pro and even
adding color correction in a lot would
be perfectly fine using Final Cut while
Premiere would require you to drop down
a half resolution which is still very
usable but that's not the case for
editing in DaVinci Resolve which likes
to have more video memory like on the 15
inch with dedicated graphics overall
we're impressed with how this MacBook
Pro performs but keep in mind that final
exports will require some patience
compared to the 15-inch MacBook Pros
about two to three times longer than
your project length and Final Cut Pro or
up to 10 times longer in Premiere so
personally we'd stick with Final Cut for
most people that do simple 4k editing
from time to time this new MacBook Pro
will do a surprisingly good job
absolutely smoking the previous model
thanks to the quad-core CPU and updated
graphics the same thing goes for photo
editing but here the performance
difference between the 13 inch and 15
inch models are even lower
since graphics are hardly used importing
50 42 megapixel RAW images into
Lightroom classic was very quick and
exporting edited JPEGs was also really
impressive we did notice a small delay
in some tasks that we don't get on our
13-inch MacBook Pro with 16 gigs of ram
which makes sense since the 8 gigabytes
of RAM are maxed out while editing
photos upgrading to 16 gigs of ram will
not only smooth out your editing
experience but speed up exporting as
well if you're doing 12 to 24 megapixel
images and small batches 8 gigabytes
will perform well enough but if you're
working with higher resolution files or
doing things like HDR panorama are
working with hundreds of images we would
highly recommend spending $200 more and
upgrading to 16 gigabytes of RAM we also
decided to include some programming
tests but unfortunately us being video
editors with absolutely no Xcode
experience at all we weren't able to
find and run a sample Xcode project that
would be easy to replicate on future
machines so if you guys know of a sample
Xcode project we could use comment below
but from
what we've seen so far with this machine
you're getting truly impressive
processor performance for the cash out
of this 1.4 gigahertz CPU and we think
it's gonna perform much better than its
windows rivals and completely blow the
2019 MacBook Air out of the water well
be getting their hands on that soon and
doing a full comparison so make sure to
subscribe so you see that and now let's
talk about the downsides when we first
got this laptop we decided to take off
the bottom cover and compare the
internals to the $1,800 MacBook Pro and
we found a few interesting details first
off we're only getting a single fan in
the base model compared to two on the
more expensive pro but seeing as we got
such impressive performance results with
CPU temps that were only slightly hotter
than the $1,800 model that doesn't seem
to be a problem we also noticed that the
speaker's look way different and when we
tested them we noticed a huge
improvement on the more expensive
13-inch Pro just listen for yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and then we tested the SSD storage speed
and found that the 128 gigabyte SSD was
quite a bit slower than the 256 gig on
the $1,800 model and not only that but
if you paid the extra two hundred
dollars to get the 256 gig SSD it's
actually still slower than the 256 gig
on the $1,800 Pro so there are a couple
of downsides already but the biggest
difference is that the $1,300 model only
gets two Thunderbolt three ports while
the more expensive one gets four of them
so we can see that while the new base
macbook pro offers incredible value for
performance there are a few things that
you have to sacrifice but let's take a
look at all these things from my own
personal opinion and past experiences as
far as performance goes I think this
machine is the way to go if you don't do
professional work everyday or if you're
doing entry-level basic stuff like
editing YouTube videos or if you're
doing your work every single day or if
your business depends on it like editing
wedding videos then I would honestly
recommend just jumping to the 15-inch
model with dedicated graphics or if
you're doing a lot of photo editing or
programming I think just getting 16 gigs
of RAM on this model would be a great
choice for almost everyone and for the
single fan we didn't really notice
higher temps at all one difference we
noticed between this and the dual fan
model was that the single fan would keep
blowing at max fan speed during longer
tasks like exporting while the dual fan
would eventually slow down a bit after
temps came down but as far as
performance itself the single fan is
completely fine now for the speakers I
personally like to watch YouTube videos
shows and movies on my macbook so that's
actually the most important thing for
myself personally now if you prefer to
use headphones and you like to watch
youtube videos on your phone and shows
on your TV then the speaker difference
won't really matter that much to you and
in reality the $1,300 models speakers
are still better than practically any
Windows laptop out there asked for the
SSD speed difference even the slower
speeds of the 128 gig model are nearly
as fast as a lot of the premium laptops
out there like Dells XPS so it'll be
fine for most people so you should
really
just worry about the storage amount
itself unless you know you need faster
speeds and finally I think the factory
eight gates of RAM would be okay for a
lot of people but I personally love to
keep a lot of chrome tabs open so if
you're like me you'll be much better off
with 16 gigs of ram and especially if
you're doing productivity tasks more
than once or twice a week for the ports
I found that I don't really use them
that often
but even then it's really convenient to
be able to swap the charger to the other
side so it's a lot more convenient and I
also like to charge my phone using a USB
c2 lightening cable so that's already
maxing out two ports so if I needed to
plug something in and transfer some
files I need to unplug one of them on
the $1,300 model so if you're planning
on actively using the Thunderbolt 3
ports like for connecting an external
display or workin off on an external
drive you probably be better off going
for the $1,800 model with 4 ports now
you could make it work with a
Thunderbolt 3 hub off Amazon but it's
not as convenient to carry that around
but if you're a simple person who only
needs those ports for charging and
occasionally connecting an external
drive for some quick file transfers that
you should honestly just be fine with
those two ports one last question we
want to address that some of you may be
asking is if it's worth buying a
discount at 2018 for port model instead
of a lower and 2019 model now the 2018
versions perform almost as good as the
2019 in terms of CPU but they do have
keyboards that have an older design
personally if you were gonna buy a
$1,500 256 gig 2019 MacBook Pro and can
score an older 4 thunderbolt model for
up to $100 more we would make that jump
since you also get better speakers and
faster SSDs but only if you can get 16
gigs of RAM on that 2018 model all in
all if you want to get access to mac OS
and not have to worry about performance
issues in the future I think the 2019
based MacBook Pro for $1,300 is the best
value MacBook in years and I think
almost everyone will be happy with that
if you enjoyed this review make sure to
tap that like button and click the
circle above to subscribe so you don't
miss out on more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
[Music]